[Music]
all right as we continue on Hannity
while President Trump continually fends
off the resistance the Clintons ever
notice they seem to always get a free
pass well today the Daily Caller
reporting the FBI has raided the home of
a whistleblower who testified they
actually gave documents pertaining to
the Clinton Foundation and uranium 1 to
a government watchdog you want real
Russia collusion the real story with
real evidence real proof I'll remember
the Clinton State Department multiple
other agencies they approved the
transfer of 20% of US Iranian to that
Russian company and by the way interests
linked to the Iranian one deal gave
millions and millions to the Clinton
Foundation and just today Judicial Watch
announced that they are suing for
documents about the efforts by the Obama
DOJ to shut down an investigation into
the foundation what about the
Foundation's silence on all their
donations from the Saudis and other
foreign governments that we have
documented on this program hardly a peep
from the mainstream media any of this
here with reaction by the way the host
of Huckabee Mike Huckabee's with us Fox
News contributor Tammy
Bruce is back with us you know I look at
the Iranian one deal and I know William
Campbell and I interviewed him and he
saw the bribery extortion kickbacks
money laundering and Putin but Putin's
thugs here in America Tammy and Robert
mullah will happen to be the FBI
director at the time he's getting the
information the sale went through was
approved the money are kicked back not a
peep in the media now just like there's
no peep in the media about the phony
Russian dossier that Hillary paid for
yeah why well look the system is
established to protect and for things
like this this is why you had such a
sloppy system with the Hillary campaign
there's been such a level of protection
that they haven't had to be careful and
and suddenly thank goodness because the
American people and Donald Trump that
environment changed and they were
unprepared this has been going on well
who knows how long generation certainly
certainly through the 20th century so
the system is meant to do this and it's
course it's it's a mutant kind of system
that protects the the bad guys we're in
the process of changing that and it's
going to take more than two years or one
term or two years it's going to take at
least a generation to move us out of
this corrupt kind of framework and of
course it's going to fight back and when
you've got the entire monster geared to
fighting back it takes somebody really
strong and it takes the American people
this is we you know we're the bulwark
here that legacy media has abandoned
their job and the American people are
the ones now through thank goodness the
internet new media multiple modes of
communication cable television that
makes the difference so so we're going
to be able to do it but the
communication framework is going to be
different for example governor so you
have all these people in the Senate
Judiciary
I believe whatever the charge that they
believed at all but they didn't say a
word about the charges not 36 years ago
about keith Ellison
emotional and physical abuse they didn't
they all love the Clintons we know all
the allegations against bill they didn't
say a word about avenatti he wasn't
going to give Brett Kavanaugh due
process and presumption of innocence so
it's not the issue they care about the
politics they care about
just like here Russia collusion but not
if it's Hillary's dossier or uranium one
giving 20% of America's uranium to the
hostile regime of Vladimir Putin thought
Russia was so bad that they would want
to join us and really get to the bottom
of it well this isn't about truth
justice of the American Way this is
about raw power and keeping it and if
you lose it then get it back even if you
have to try to overturn the results of
an election and that's why it should be
so very troubling so I don't think you
or anybody else in America truly
believes that Bill Clinton gave a speech
that was worth half a million dollars in
Moscow while his wife happened to be the
Secretary of State and amazingly and
coincidentally it just happened that the
uranium one deal came through FBI
director
was Bob Muller I don't think he's
investigating that while he's got this
incredible unit of Democrats that he's a
symbol to do investigation of Russia
collusion
the real Russia collision is seemingly
going uninvestigated
yeah but we're like an island here
bringing up news and information with
evidence something they don't have
against Donald Trump and yet it
penetrates and it penetrates and I bet
anything Muller is going to use a
sledgehammer to try and bludgeon in his
report Donald Trump well there's no
doubt about that but the one thing that
has to happen is that the president has
to appoint a permanent Attorney General
not not a temporary like Whitaker maybe
it's Lindsey Graham maybe it's trey
Gowdy I don't know maybe it's sean
hannity for heaven's sakes I wouldn't
get one vote yeah you know what it's
probably a bad idea they'll never
confirm you that's for sure
they gotta have someone Sean who is
going to be relentless not in trying to
be a harsh to the Democrats but trying
to be fair to the truth but no matter it
bothers let me add because the person
that is going to do the best job is
going to be the person that the
Democrats freaked out about the most
this is why the Senate as it exists now
the new the newbies coming in even with
Romney we've got to make sure the
president makes it clear to Mitch
McConnell and every other senator and
the Republican Party that that this
matters that his next Attorney General
must be confirmed that they cannot allow
the Democrats to muck up the waters and
change this framework everything is at
stake because the person who's right for
that office in every appointee if the
president is going to upset people
specifically because they intend to
clean house and that's what's important
here all right guys great analysis we'll
stay on it we'll do their job eventually
hopefully the truth comes out